check out this story from the
independent
biggest crash in world history personal
finance expert robert kiyosaki predicts
economic crisis in october a crash is a
really good time to get rich says author
of rich dad poor dad now i don't believe
him
it's a bit much to be like this month
it'll happen
however i don't not believe him
you know because we just had bob murphy
on the economist phd economists say that
they remove the restriction require the
restrictions on on reserve fractional
reserve banking the reserve requirement
so basically banks can just
print money and
give it out
yeah so let me just read a little bit
they say personal finance expert robert
kiyosaki warned the crash is coming
regardless of whether the us debt
ceiling is raised or what measures are
imposed by treasury secretary janet
yellen or federal reserve chair jerome
powell this is going to be the biggest
crash in world history we have never had
this much debt pumped up the debt to gdp
ratio is out of sight mr kiyosaki said
the stock market was being artificially
inflated by the treasury department and
the federal reserve with decisions
disconnected from the realities of the
current economy in the u.s
the reason why ms yellen and mr powell
are scrambling he said is they've
expanded the volume of money while the
velocity of money is plummeting as no
one spends and their crash and their
cash lingers in savings
he says quote
so they pump all this money in prices go
up
so it is a tran it is transitory
inflation but we're stacked with this
massive debt and all it's done is bump
up the stock market and real estate
market the money has not gone into the
economy that's the sad part so the rich
get richer but the poor and middle class
are getting poorer it's tragic what's
happening today you can't keep printing
fake money that's not good
[Music]
i've noticed it when i was buying my
crystals and rocks as i told you
especially my opals
people aren't spending so the people
that have this load of assets they need
to unload have to drop the price these
people are cutting slashing their prices
by 80 percent to offload their assets so
the rich people can buy up all the
assets now yeah because desperate people
are selling but that's non-essentials at
the same time the land for instance
people are like wow they're desperate to
get out of cities the stuff they really
need the prices are skyrocketing so
what's going to if there is a crash what
would happen to like land prices
skyrocket they would score here's here's
my bet there's a lot of arguments you
could give to why land would crash
because if people don't have money they
can't buy so that means people are
trying to sell we have to lower their
prices or it could be that land is a
necessity and people in cities who can't
afford to live anymore will be desperate
to leave so which will which will
it'll put the pressure on those trying
to leave what we're seeing right now in
my opinion the crash is happening the m1
money stock is is is insane even after
they change the the definitions and the
rules
and you've got people trying to leave
cities for the country i've i'm seeing
it in these prices it is insane how much
money we have to spend to try and expand
even into west virginia because people
are like my garbage land is now worth
you know
a fortune
so what i think would happen is if the
crash gets worse it will just continue
the trend we're already seeing people in
new york will be like i don't need opals
please buy the opals for me i don't and
they're going to be like
what's it worth it's a hundred dollar
i'll give you 20 bucks fine please just
take it and by the way i can't do
anything with it i'm buying the opals to
teach children about rocks and stones
that's the investment
i love it this is the point i've always
made you know when alex jones with
santa's show buy your gold people i'd be
like okay it's the apocalypse the
economy is crashing and i'm walking down
the street and i see a guy with a big
old pile of gold and i've got a sandwich
in my hands and he says hey i'll buy
that sandwich off off you for a piece of
gold and i say i look to my right
there's a guy with a bottle of water and
he says i'll share my water with you and
for some of your sandwich and i'll be
like i'm thirsty and that's
substantially more valuable than a shiny
rock
and they'll say hey you want water and
food but you don't have money for it
what do you what do you have to offer us
blood literally you can donate blood we
need your biometrics i don't i don't
know
in an apocalypse like you know what
would you trade because what's going on
necessities are going to skyrocket like
water and food is going to skyrocket yes
and if people can't afford it what do
they have to offer other than their own
bodies this is yes that's a good point
but i was i was saying like in the
analogy on the side of the road i didn't
quite understand why someone inside a
road would be like i have an iv i know
isn't that crazy but yeah um people have
to they'll do a lot of things they'll do
a lot of things trying to survive but i
asked this question before
what is the one thing
that is mo is the hardest to produce but
is extremely as commonly used in homes
chemicals yeah
well i said antiseptics yeah
i don't think most people know how to
make an antiseptic you can probably make
a rudimentary alcohol if you know how to
you know distill things yeah but that's
not super easy so i'm thinking like what
is the hardest thing to produce that we
use every day soap
soap's not that hard to make
but but yes relative to how frequently
it's used it's kind of soap is good but
i feel like antiseptics so i bought a
bunch of mouthwash and isopropyl alcohol
and hydrogen peroxide things that like
in the event of an injury you want to
clean your wound because back in the day
you gotta you stub your toe and it's
like chop your leg off you got an
infection yeah
one vitamins two
yes oh yeah yeah i think this that's one
of the positives over the last year and
a half of people realizing we should
take vitamins yep i take
c d b and uh a multivitamin and
magnesium ever since the the pandemic
that's almost zinc yeah as needed notice
people washing their hands in public
restrooms
there are a lot of people who have
urban property investments that are
going to drop to nothing
no one's going to want to be in new york
city when they're struggling to get
resources into the city it's so hard
yeah and so if you bought a condo or
apartment in new york i can't imagine
you're having a good go of it trying to
try to get out of there especially with
the with the lockdowns yeah like uh an
hour and a half of north of the new york
city
there are homes that were two hundred
thousand dollars that are now six
hundred seven hundred thousand dollars
right and people are moving there and
it's like a lot of my friends i'm 36 a
lot of our parents moved up from the
city
in the 80s so they witnessed the
collapse of the city in the 70s when
everything was on fire and it was
terrible it was bankrupt um so now all
of that hour and a half north is kind of
full although people are now moving to
go maybe to florida but the uh hour now
north of us is what's being filled in
you know upstate upstate real upstate
new york have you noticed
i don't know if you've checked city
prices though have they been going down
i haven't
i can't imagine yeah they're spiking
right now but you made a great point
that that the real value of city land is
not going to escalate if it gets
difficult to oh it's going to be like an
escape from new york people are great
movie by the way great movies
i was i was there when when sandy hit
new york
and like
i went to a bodega that was two i was
like i'm hungry i was about bodega they
had two guys standing outside with two
by fours and a line of people waiting
again one at a time they were only
allowed in and i went in the guy said
the stuff in the fridge is all spoiled
but the the dry goods are still
good and i was like okay and then i
looked in the fridge and it's like okay
the gatorade is still good you know the
the the sodas are just warm
but all the milk all the dairy all the
perishables just gone so this is an
interesting concept like
things that have value this is what i
was thinking about when people are
buying like even nfts i think nfts will
probably drop dramatically in value if
there's an economic crash
yeah they're just art basically but
maybe not maybe not i mean that's one
way to use them as art you can do it for
contracts and stuff like that right
i think those i think nfts will probably
go down but i do think crypto would
skyrocket because people are going to
need a digital means of transaction in
the event it becomes harder with these
with with you know the way banks operate
but we'll see i don't know if the
banking system would be you know as
negatively affected but if businesses
start if banks aren't going under and
you know banks are closing and then all
of a sudden you're you're like where's
my where's my money but i will say like
i think there are certain hard assets
that will become substantially less
valuable or stay the same
and then
rural land is probably going to become
massively valuable realistically how
valuable is gold anyway
i mean i know it's useful as like a
superconductor but actually really
really valuable yeah for the common
person though no yeah it's really
valuable the problem is we value it for
its like
you know it's it's
shining shininess instead of its
scientific processes right you know it's
it's a scarce
valuable object the scarcity drives it
we do use it in a lot of technologies
and it's extremely valuable in that
regard but we don't really value it for
that that that value does help drive up
the cost though but i think
i don't know if we'll get to that point
with economic collapse where like a
bottle of water will be worth a hundred
dollars oh yeah that could happen easily
it could but i don't know if we'll get
to that point even if even if we face a
major economic crisis people still work
people still make stuff you know i'm
thinking about how crazy everything's
gotten and i'm watching fox news and i'm
like
you know what i realize people watch the
news and the news is doing the same
thing it always does the guy because you
know bill hammer is on tv and he's like
afghanistan happens and they assume like
see everything's fine like my because
they assume like the
tv would shut off like in the movies yo
go to any one of these countries look at
the history of any one of these
countries i went to revolution even
afghanistan
the economy is still struggling along
even in afghanistan people are still
working people are still going out and
buying food it doesn't just cease to
exist so you can absolutely be watching
your tv program while the world is
collapsing around you not realize it be
because this tv show is giving you this
like this veil they pick and choose the
apocalypse right like if it's a a
migrant caravan
a few years ago that's all we saw on the
news if it's in my micro caravan now you
don't really see much of it you gotta go
with voters attendance you gotta go to
the ventura report on instagram to see
jorge standing there recording them
taking votes across
talking about the border yeah you know
it's i don't think they're annoying i
think it's a huge story but yeah we had
i mean now they're estimating 400 000
migrants you know coming up the next
month and i look at that and i'm just
like look
call it pessimistic or just call it what
it is
how can you watch all this happen and
then say tim is wrong the republic is in
good shape we had a guest on the show
i'm not going to call him out after the
show he was he asked me or like we were
talking i don't know if he asked me if i
brought it up something about like you
know you really think things are going
to fall apart and i was like they're
literally falling apart and he was like
nah i think it's fine i think this is
just like you know news and everything's
gonna be fine and then i was like
how can you witness the street violence
the shootings the firebombings the the
executive authority the rule by edict
the january what happened on january 6
antifa riots and just be like nothing is
happening i'm like yo history is
happening right now in your face but
you're a frog in a pot as the water is
turning up and you don't even realize it
yeah i'm always trying to make sure that
i'm not
saying that it's this is the end because
i'm always like kind of paranoid i'm
like this this has got to be the end but
then when it starts to be the end like a
covet hits and it starts to filter i'm
like no it's fine right but my
grandfather was a cop in the city in the
70s
that was the end for him
right like but also when he was younger
he saw an atom bomb fall out of the sky
i mean he thought was the end then yeah
but this feels different maybe because
we're of a certain age and experiencing
it we might have families and houses and
all that stuff and all that's collapsing
but something does feel
different than what my grandfather would
tell them i think maybe the issue is
that we call it the end when it's not
the end it's a change it's the
transition yeah for sure you know the
the american empire
uh couldn't last forever soviets
couldn't last forever
and that's what's happening you know so
i i said this the other day and maybe
it's a good thing maybe what happens is
if you live in new hampshire
all of a sudden the country breaks apart
the federal government has no authority
as we've already seen with california
sanctuary state decree the fed emperor
has no clothes so now all of a sudden
it's like okay you got no income tax and
you can have guns
i don't think people in new hampshire
are going to be upset about what's going
on and i think people will absolutely
adapt to the circumstances meaning
they'll raise their own food
there's you know people will it's gonna
be a hole in the market someone's gonna
be like hey now now that we're
struggling to get the imports in we
can't get avocados or strawberries
because those are seasonal and have to
cross you know very very far require a
lot
we uh we we don't have a whole lot of
food out here then someone's gonna be
like i could grow food and make money
doing it
farming will become more valuable it'll
go back to basics people start valuing
good hard work all over again there's a
lot of value in that because
people are gonna spend more time with
their families
they're going to be more responsible for
themselves and get away from this you
know
i don't know
just start naming off the seven deadly
sins and you can describe new york city
yeah and that'll start changing maybe
for the better yeah that's why i'm not
completely depressed about everything it
seems it's really bad but
i like that i like that people are
returning to that kind of thing it's
actually a super red pill to me and this
is something that i've been talking
about a little bit because i feel like
you know the cycle weak men create bad
times bad times create strong men well
we're going into bad times we're going
to come up with some really strong
people i think that's good i think
that's positive and i think that's
something humans have been doing for
thousands of years there's no reason to
suspect that this would be any different
so to me that's very positive yeah yeah
my uh you know
my grandparents their parents fled
pogroms in russia oh wow there were
people running to their towns with axes
whoa and hacking them up and uh they
left and they took a boat to here
and when they got there this is my
grandma's father
one of four children
he had a scab on his head they said you
got to go back
so she went back with the with the kids
to the pogroms and had to hide out for
the scab to heal and then take the boat
back wow
right oh my gosh that's apocalyptic
right yeah they made it and i i have a
grandmother they had to go back because
the scar would have given the person
away as a flear no it was it was it was
like a from just like a a cut that he
had from something else but it could be
disease or something it could be disease
that's what they were thinking yeah
they're like we don't know what this is
you could leave the kid or send the kid
back and you say here um that's bold so
think of that thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you